ahora que ya estudiamos a los carbó
cationes y sus reglas veamos nuevamente
la reacción de eliminación 1 en donde
hacemos reaccionar diferentes alcoholes
con ácido sulfúrico y la deshidratación
de esos alcoholes forma al que nos como
productos aquí tenemos un alcohol
ustedes qué opinan será un alcohol
primario secundario o terciario bueno el
carbono que está unido a lo h este de
aquí está unido a otros 2 carbonos por
lo que es un alcohol secundario
aplicaremos lo mismo que hicimos con los
carbó cationes los re arreglos en los
alcoholes son posibles si en el
mecanismo hay un carbó catión aquí
tendríamos un carbó catión secundario y
en el mecanismo se puede regular para
formar un carbó catión terciario por eso
un alcohol terciario no tiene arreglos
mientras que para los alcoholes
primarios la red
es la más lenta el carb ocasión siempre
buscará un re arreglo más estable
regresemos a nuestro ejemplo de alcohol
secundario vamos a ver para el re
arreglo del mecanismo por el ácido
sulfúrico hay protones flotando en la
solución pondré un protón aquí
un par de electrones solitarios del
oxígeno tomará este protón y se da una
reacción ácido base dibujemos el
producto
aquí está nuestro oxígeno uno de sus
pares de electrones no reaccionó el otro
par formó un enlace con el protón el
hidrógeno y originalmente ya teníamos un
hidrógeno por acá están los grupos
metilo el oxígeno quedó con una carga
formal más uno tiene un solo par de
electrones libres pero como al oxígeno
no le gusta nada tener una carga formal
positiva porque no tiene muchos
electrones estos electrones se irán con
el oxígeno para que sea feliz y así
perdemos agua en esta etapa dibujaré
agua flotando por ahí
como el agua sale el oxígeno recupera
otro par de electrones y aquí nos quedo
lo voy a dibujar aquí está el anillo de
ciclohexano y nuestros dos grupos metilo
pero como este carbono perdió el enlace
que tenía con el oxígeno se quedó con
una carga formal positiva nos ha quedado
un kart vocación y qué tipo de carbó
cationes bueno este carbono está unido a
otros dos carbonos así que es un kart
vocación secundario y para un kart
vocación secundario el rea regló es
posible para formar un kart vocación
terciario en este caso podemos tener una
transposición de metilo uno de estos
grupos de metilo de la derecha puede
emigrar a esta parte para formar un
nuevo enlace con este carbono dibujemos
lo que pasa
aquí tenemos al ciclohexano y el grupo
metilo se pasó a este carbono por acá ya
estaba el grupo metilo justo aquí y que
hay de la carga formal bueno como este
carbono perdió un metilo solía tener
cuatro enlaces pero ahora sólo tiene
tres aún conserva un hidrógeno por lo
que tiene una carga formal positiva más
1 entonces la carga formal se movió de
este carbono al carbono de la derecha
después de la transposición por lo que
ahora tenemos al kart vocación aquí este
carbono está unido a 123 carbonos es un
carbón catión terciario la transposición
de metilo nos ayudó a formar un kart
vocación terciario que es más estable
que uno secundario
si funcionó el re arreglo y finalmente
en el último paso del mecanismo
necesitamos formar el al que no para eso
necesitamos una base este par de
electrones de la molécula de agua pueden
actuar como una base y tomarán
únicamente al protón dejando a estos
electrones que formarán el doble enlace
deshaciéndonos así de la carga positiva
dibujemos el alc en lo que resulta
aquí teníamos un grupo metilo y el doble
enlace se forma justo aquí este es
nuestro producto en el que note atrás
sustituido por la vida de un kart
vocación terciario y es el producto que
obtendremos en mayor cantidad porque
como hemos dicho el kart vocación
terciario es el más estable ahora
sigamos a los electrones durante el
mecanismo para entender mejor
en el primer paso estos electrones estos
de aquí formaron un nuevo enlace con ese
protón así que estos dos electrones
son los que están acá estos y otros
electrones que podemos seguir son a
estos dos los que se fueron con el
oxígeno que serían estos de aquí muy
bien y que me dicen de los electrones de
la transposición de metilo estos fueron
los electrones involucrados que
terminaron moviéndose hacia acá y por
último estos electrones que formaron el
doble enlace y así fue cómo se formó
nuestro al que no listo si gana los
electrones en sus mecanismos y siempre
que exista la formación de un kart
vocación piensen en los posibles
arreglos que pueda haber
hagamos otro ejemplo veamos esta
reacción
empecemos con este alcohol lo primero
que hay que hacer es clasificarlo como
primario secundario o terciario este
carbono que está unido directamente al
oxígeno está unido a otro carbono es un
alcohol primario si se acuerdan los
alcoholes primarios siempre buscarán un
re arreglo cuando se tenga un carbó
catión aquí se formará un kart vocación
primario veamos cómo se forma nuevamente
hacemos reaccionar nuestro alcohol con
ácido sulfúrico entonces hay protones
flotando por aquí y un par de electrones
libres del oxígeno tomarán un protón la
primera reacción es ácido base protón
amosal oxígeno y sólo le queda un par de
electrones libres y este formó un enlace
con el hidrógeno ahora el oxígeno tiene
una carga formal más o no
ahí está nuestro oxígeno quedó cargado
positivamente con lo que no está feliz
así que para deshacerse de esa carga el
enlace entre este carbono y el oxígeno
se romperá y los electrones se irán
junto con el oxígeno que nos queda
tenemos 4 carbonos y la molécula de agua
quedó flotando el oxígeno ahora tiene
dos pares de electrones libres en donde
quedó la carga formal positiva a donde
se fue bueno terminó en este carbono
como perdió un enlace ahora este es
nuestro carbó catión que es un kart
vocación primario porque el carbono solo
está unido a este carbono como un kart
vocación primario no es para nada
estable buscará un re arreglo pero qué
tipo de regla bueno sabemos que aquí hay
algunos hidrógenos así que para este
caso podemos tener una transposición de
hidruro puedo tomar a este hidrógeno y
junto con este par de electrones
moverlos para formar un enlace con este
carbono vamos a ver si ocurre la
transposición de hidruro tenemos a
nuestros cuatro carbonos y movemos a
este hidrógeno
aquí solo me queda un hidrógeno y acá ya
tenemos dos hidrógenos
2 ahora a dónde se movió la carga formal
positiva a este carbono porque ahora
sólo tiene tres enlaces
este es nuestro nuevo kart vocación y
qué tipo de carbó cationes bueno como
está unido a otros dos carbonos es un
kart vocación secundario que como ya
vimos es más estable que uno primario
así que ahora tenemos un kart vocación
secundario y en realidad podemos obtener
tres productos diferentes
para evitar confusiones voy a redibujar
este kart vocación tres veces para poder
ver mejor los tres productos que
resulten
como tenemos este kart vocación
secundario habrá tres posibles productos
vamos a ver en la primera situación una
posibilidad es que al tener estos dos
hidrógenos
una base que puede ser la molécula de
agua aunque mejor dibujaré una base
general para que no haya confusión
tenemos una base con un par de
electrones libres que tomarán a este
hidrógeno y así estos electrones se
moverán para formar el doble enlace
entonces el primer producto posible
tendrá un doble enlace entre estos
carbonos queda así y es el producto
trans 2 putt en este sería el primer
posible producto y como ahora sabemos
que se forma el trans 2 bote no vamos a
pensar en los estéreo isómeros yo creo
que podría formarse el cis 2 wood en
cómo se formará recuerden los enlaces
simples son enlace sigma que rotan
libremente entonces este enlace rota
libremente y la molécula se puede ver
así
y sabemos que hay algunos hidrógenos en
este carbono aquí y aquí cuando una base
interactúa dibujaré una base por aquí
esta base puede tomar uno de estos
protones con lo que estos electrones se
moverán para formar el compuesto sis así
nos queda el compuesto 62 butano
entonces ya tenemos al trans 2 butano y
al cis 2 voten
otro posible producto se puede obtener
si en lugar de hacer reaccionar el lado
izquierdo del carbó catión reacción en
el lado derecho podemos tomar a uno de
estos hidrógenos beta aquí quedaron tres
hidrógenos después de la transposición
de hidruro en este caso podemos poner
una base por acá para que tome a este
protón y así estos electrones se moverán
hacia acá esto nos da un posible
producto con un doble enlace en la
primera posición
este es el
1 hütten o
1 bote no podemos obtener una mezcla de
estos tres productos diferentes cuál de
esos tres se producirá más sabemos que
los al que nos dé sustituidos son más
estables que los al que en los monos
sustituidos y si observamos aquí el 1
bote no es un al que no mono sustituido
entonces se producirá en menor cantidad
aproximadamente el 12% será uno
wooten y tenemos dos al que nos dé
sustituidos en donde el trans es más
estable que el cis por lo tanto el
estéreo y somero será el producto en
mayor cantidad para esta reacción por lo
tanto el estéreo y somero trans será el
producto en mayor cantidad
aproximadamente el 56 por ciento y
después el 62 voten con aproximadamente
32 por ciento
ahí están los tres productos una de las
razones por las que la química orgánica
se les dificulta algunas veces es por
todos los pasos que requieren de nuestro
pensamiento lógico pero acuérdense de
dibujar el mecanismo para entenderlo
mejor entiendan los carbó cationes y las
transposiciones intenten hacer los
problemas aunque al principio parezcan
difíciles